and armed with a 12 centimeter
circumference that's two little children
under five years of age are getting a
checkup one year old moored is among
them like a third of the children in
lowes he suffers from malnutrition his
aunt has brought him to the health
center his mother works on a coffee
plantation eighty percent of the meals
in Laos consist of rice
it's rich in calories but poor in
nutrients and vitamins which are
essential for a balanced diet benign a
coma when our parents don't feed their
children properly because they don't
know anything about nutrition when their
children become ill they're surprised
that's why it's important to check
children in rural areas for malnutrition
eating nothing but rice every day has
dire consequences for the children's
physical and mental development that's
why a health program has been instituted
focusing on education and prevention the
European Union and UNICEF have invested
1.2 million euros in local health
centers most are in southeastern Laos
where the need is greatest for kabuto
dipping bottom gongyuan severe cases of
acute malnutrition we dispense ready to
use therapeutic food which we get from
UNICEF I'm not Nick to pumpkin du Bois
rely look after two weeks we see if the
child's weight has improved or not gonna
need them like Aang diega these
nutrients in powder form are highly
concentrated and especially effective
with small children each packet contains
the recommended daily amounts of 15
vitamins and minerals to reduce anemia
and iron deficiency both symptoms of
malnutrition campaigns in village
schools teach mothers how they can
better nourish their children education
and health go hand in hand here
after the checkup Mord and his aunt
returned to their village golly yeah
daddy the doctor gave me health tips for
my nephew kappa gotta ribbon for he told
me Mort is malnourished that would move
in Flocka that now he'll be treated and
checked again in two weeks the doctor
also told me a poor diet will damage his
health deadly been probably luleå Hannah
died about kakara mord's aunt has
learned a lot about nutrition the daily
portion of rice is now accompanied by
important nutrients in addition to the
powder I'll start adding meat vegetables
and fruit to his meals so they're more
nourishing and moored gets well again
it's an ambitious plan about seventy
percent of lotions live on less than two
dollars a day for most of them rice will
remain the most important component of
their diet